hey youtubers it's Charlie so you guys
requested an Infinity Gauntlet infinity
gems video so I'm going to explain some
of the really funny quirks and secrets
of them in the cinematic universe as
well as the comics if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get
everything I do Marvel videos every week
there's even a giveaway that's going on
right now I'll explain at the end of the
video so there aren't that many
differences between the infinity gems in
the comics in the Infinity stones in the
Marvel Cinematic Universe only their
location the people that wield them in
the gauntlets themselves the big secret
of the Infinity Gauntlet in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe you may have spotted
this is that one of the gauntlets is not
with Thanos it's actually in Odin's
vault and it glows like it has all the
gems in it
Gasquet is safe and old as well always
well it broke into the weapons book if
the frost giants had stolen even one of
these relics they didn't well I want to
know why in the ultimate universe of the
comics there used to be two gauntlets
with eight gems but the powers were the
exact same in the main 6-1-6 universe
the Infinity Gauntlet storyline only
featured the one gauntlet with the six
gems soul time-space mind reality and
power the other dirty secret of the
infinity gems is that their colors
change in the comics depending on who's
drawing in writing the book so the
classic colors are actually just green
like this is what the panel looks like
they have no different color but
obviously people get confused with gem
are you wielding I don't understand
what's going on so jim Starlin writes
stano's quest that's the story of him
coming up with the idea to assemble the
gauntlet and use it to erase half of all
life in the galaxy there is an imbalance
that feels like more people are alive
today than have ever died and that is a
great cosmic imbalance Thanos hoarding
her favor wants to correct this mistake
so he goes about collecting all the gems
when we get to the Infinity Gauntlet
storyline you see the classic colors so
you see green orange purple blue yellow
red a couple years ago Brian Michael
Bendis does new avengers the illuminati
holds the infinity gem the color shifts
just a little bit and then a lot of you
are asking why are the colors different
yet again in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe the other dirty secret of the
movies is that when they started making
them a long time ago they didn't know
how it would work out so they needed to
build themselves some options down the
road so everything was fine and we got
two Avengers they teased Stannis's the
end they're like okay great we're going
to do the Infinity Gauntlet storyline
it's just a bit of a wink they totally
called it they totally hit their shot
everything went fine but initially
because they
had put so much money on the line with
Merrill Lynch and the banks that were
financing their movies they just needed
to have it out in case things didn't
work out and they couldn't build up to
something as crazy as the Infinity
Gauntlet that's why some of the earliest
versions of the infinity gems were not
gems at all even in the first Avengers
film there are two gems but they're
disguised as Loki's scepter in the
tesseract there are two reasons for that
one to build themselves and out into
just to misdirect people so they didn't
know immediately the storylines that
they were going for but they wanted
there to be some mystery when they got
to Avengers age of Ultron Joss Whedon
said that when he met for the first
Avengers film he has the idea for the
second film he mostly went into that
meeting pitching jarvis becoming the
vision which was one of the big twists
of avengers age of ultron but it's also
the idea that the mine stone forms part
of his personality so they didn't want
to give that twist away too quickly so
that's why you see Loki's scepter it
looks blue the gem that comes out of it
is yellow most versatile substance on
the planet can we use it to make a
frisbee typical of humans they scratch
the surface you never think to look
within
[Music]
the origin of the gems of the comics are
a little bit different from the origin
of the gems in the movies in the comics
they just represent different cosmic
principles and they're called the soul
gems by the Silver Surfer for the first
time in the late 80s the elders of the
universe are going to collect them and
use them to drain Galactus of his power
does that not look like a version of the
Celestials that we saw in guardians of
the galaxy assembling the gems to do
something crazy we just see the sequence
we don't know exactly what it is they're
doing this year is really an easter egg
for that the elders of the universe look
more like people they don't look like a
giant Celestials
before creation itself there were six
singularity then the universe exploded
into existence and the remnant of the
systems were forged into concentrated
pink infinity stone he stones it seems
can only be brandished by beings of
extraordinary strength observe
and couriers been used to slow down
higher civilizations like wheat in a
field this is all P coming at me right
now once for a moment that group was
able to share the energy amongst
themselves but even they was quickly
destroyed by beautiful beyond compare
Bob the movie gems like the collector
says are remnant from systems that
existed from before creation itself when
the Big Bang happened the energy that
was left from those previous six systems
was forged into gems by the Celestials
so that's what you're seeing here and
nowhere the city that they travel to
where the collector has his base is
actually the severed head of an
unidentified celestial they don't know
which one it is it just gives you an
idea of how big and powerful they are so
for instance a lot of you asked how
Peter quill is able to hold one of the
infinity gems without being destroyed
his father is ego the Living Planet this
is how big he is
he's millions of years old so it's
almost like ego the Living Planet is on
par with the Celestials but he's not a
celestial he's not that powerful as of
right now in the movie the space gem is
still at Asgard they took it back there
at the end of the first Avengers film
the mind gem is still envisioned for
head the reality gem is still with the
collector the power gem is still with
the Nova Corps the time gem is still
with dr. strange
[Music]
oh mama
I come to bargain
wise choice know where the i iveco mojo
once you've mastered its powers until
then it's not to walk the streets
wearing an infinity stone a watt and we
have yet to see the soldier there are a
number of places that it could show up
depending on how their powers will work
it will either be with hella because she
does have the ability to cold souls
which is the ability of the soldier the
ability to control people's souls or the
new option that a lot of people are
wondering about is if it might be inside
the hollow tree in the necropolis in
Black Panthers city of Wakanda they have
this very mystical connection with the
afterlife that normal characters don't
have Black Panther king of Wakanda
is also king of the Dead is that he also
can communicate with previous Black
Panthers if they wanted to they could
shoehorn in that explanation to the soul
gem but it just depends on how
real-world they're going to keep the
Black Panther character in that movie we
won't really find out til next year but
the cool thing is is that you won't have
to wait that long because it's coming in
February we deal with royalty we deal
with royal families but unlike our other
films right here on earth you get to
explore different cultures and different
aspects of our world for black panther
and the world of Wakanda it's finding
those real-life touchstones that we
think gives the film and integrity yet
still making it something that you've
never seen before there are two more
really big secrets in the MCU one are
they going to actually kill anybody
during Avengers infinity war I'll do a
separate video about that coke by Norman
Mailer all true stories in the death
these guys are playing massively high
state games and if people don't die
occasionally it's there's no reality I
mean it's not reality to begin with but
we have to at least give it a semblance
of reality every so often in another
video that I'll be doing is which
Avengers are capable of actually
wielding the Infinity Gauntlet because
you have to imagine that Peter quill was
able to hold on to it for a little while
and his father is ego the Living Planet
so there are only a few characters that
are on the Avengers roster that are
capable of wielding infinity gems
without being destroyed so let me know
in the
comment who do you want to see wield the
Infinity Gauntlet from The Avengers
roster now there have been humans that
have wielded the gauntlet Tony Stark was
able to do it for a brief period the
Hulk even wielded the Infinity Gauntlet
there were two of them in the Ultimate
Universe so there are human characters
that have been able to do it in the past
they might decide to bend the rules for
the movies because there are a couple
characters that I really want to see
holding that gauntlet but what's going
to happen later tonight is there's a
really big DC TV flash arrow legend
panels it's happening at PaleyFest I'll
do a video for the stuff that they
announce at that so that will be posting
later tonight there'll be new Game of
Thrones and new Walking Dead posting
tomorrow leave all your Marvel video
requests in the comments below
congratulations to the new giveaway
winner a mayor oh you win the Spider Man
action figures please private message me
on the back end of my channel there was
a new round that started in this video
on ounce the winner when I post my next
Marvel video while you wait for that
click here for more Marvel post-credit
scenes and you can click here to learn
about the new venom movies that Sony
just announced thank you so much for
watching I'll see you guys in the next
video